this handshake is a sign of hope for  many divided Korean families for 100  North and South Koreans it means a  chance to see their loved ones again  after decades of forced separation his  anger John wonder combo dogging the  south and the North both one to work to  fundamentally resolve humanitarian  issues with regards to the problems of  the separated families so far the policy  has seen only modest success family  reunification began in two thousand and  meetings were supposed to take place  annually following tensions over North  Korean nuclear policies the program was  temporarily suspended but in October it  is set to resume critics say too few  people are allowed a chance to take part  in South Korea alone sixty-six thousand  people are on a red cross waiting list  and many are already in their 70s or 80s  and may not live to see their loved ones  again